it's a shame to see a classic American
company like American Girl betray
American parents and American girls that
is actually teaching them self-loathing
it's not teaching them confidence or
body positivity and it's very what is
that okay so there's this book that
American Girls is expensive doll company
you can buy designer clothes for the
doll they but they do have all different
kinds of you know everybody's shape size
disabilities you know all different
dolls they didn't start out that way of
course like any doll company they
started out with perfect beautiful dolls
and they've gone you know more inclusive
which is fine and cute but they turn
they they put this book out earlier this
year it's called the SMART Girls guide
to body image and How To Love Yourself
live life to the fullest and celebrate
all kinds of bodies and in it it's it's
geared for girls age I believe three to
twelve but three is a little young
because you can't read but it's
basically giving them an out to being a
young girl because your body can get
uncomfortable and it can feel weird so
let us tell you about all the other
things that that you can be you can go
to your doctor and get puberty blockers
or if your parents are mean and they
won't talk to you about this here's all
these other places you can go to and
they'll talk to you about it this is
real this is a major American toy
company pushing transgenderism and
putting harsh body image ideas into
young girls I can tell you I was a young
girl once and I was awkward simply
squatty had braces greasy flat hair I
looked like howdy Duty without the
freckles it was gross okay just
dorkarama okay and yeah there were other
girls who were prettier or I looked in
magazines and they were beautiful girls
and I would feel a little shy or feel
awkward that is part of growing up okay
tough [ __ ] well that was just a sampling
of the parents who are sounding off on
the controversial new book from the
behind the American Girl doll the
company has yet to comment on the
growing backlash against its new book
for girls the book promotes gender
Transitions and points to resources that
can help children if they don't have a
parent
or an adult the evil liberal agenda
Center former California gubernatorial
candidate and a Fox News contributor
Caitlin it is great to see you and great
to have you on this today for our
viewers who may not be totally up to
speed yet on this the book just dropped
yesterday we picked it up down the
street here in Rock Center uh
Caitlyn parts of your body may make you
feel uncomfortable the book aimed at
children in the single digit age range
reads and you may want to change the way
you look that's totally okay if you
haven't gone through puberty yet the
doctor might offer medicine to delay
your body's changes if you don't have an
adult you trust there are organizations
across the country that can help you
what is Caitlyn Jenner's reaction to
this book
well it's not a good reaction I'm a
parent raised a lot of girls
and what bothers me about this book It
also says a smart Girl's Guide to body
image like if you're really smart you're
going to have problems with your body
image this is again another example of
the woke world just going crazy uh
American Girl certainly has the right uh
to do this book They're a private
company
but the effects and the backlash they're
going to get they have to accept look
what happened to Disney the exact same
happened at Disney
um uh Disney what is that wait they have
dudes Logan I don't know if Logan is a a
dude or a transgender I don't know doll
there's no way I'm giving my my son like
boy dolls like that's just with an
American Girl box like if I got that
when I was little I'd have been like
what the [ __ ] is this it's just weird
Disney went woke on us here and it a
hundred and fifteen dollars high-end
this is a high-end that's such a scam
the drum set the drum set is 68 for a
doll to have a fake drum set is 68 I bet
you would cost them no more than 50 75
cents to produce no probably not some
some good marks slave labor in China but
that's why that's why I love marketing
and fine I find branding so fascinating
you convince people that they're doing a
good by buying this you know what my the
funniest thing to me is is like when
influencers do like a merge drop or
something and they're like I know you
guys have wanted more merch so we're
doing two drops this month or a holiday
sale or something and the fans are like
yeah and it's like you just they're
getting so amped to make you like a
million dollars it's just funny because
it's like it's not necessarily a bad
thing either but the way you word it and
you make The Branding and Market it it's
in a way to trick them into thinking
they're you're doing a good thing for
them but having them give you money we
would just talk yeah I mean we were just
and it's not about it that's why
marketing has emotional triggers where
the CEO had to had to leave Bob Byer
came in to try to fix all of this stuff
uh Miracle corporations have to realize
that the parent is attached to that yeah
this is supposed to be kid a kid's book
a little kid's book so the audio clip
that I had didn't even get into gender
it just was like uh imagine a scenario
where you get invited to your classmates
pool party on Saturday what's your
reaction option A can't wait to you know
test out you know my new you know
Cannonball B I'm not as pretty as Trina
or oh
I I'm I'm I'm too fat for my swimsuit
I'm just gonna say I'm sick so I don't
have to pretend I'm sick so I don't have
to put it on option D oh gosh um my my
hips are are awkward or whatever like it
had this list of stressors that little
girls may not have even thought of yet
and this book is putting it into their
heads poisoning them making them
stressed out you know like as a mother
when you were a little kid I didn't go
hey hey you know one of your ears is
different from the other yeah don't get
self-conscious I don't care let's go to
the party now like no you don't like you
don't put [ __ ] negative [ __ ] in kids
Heads This is emotional abuse and
they're positioning it as you know
helping those children who are
uncomfortable you know what get [ __ ]
used to being uncomfortable that's it
that's how you're gonna get stronger in
life that's how you're gonna get things
done that's how you're gonna succeed you
did not call me my prono yeah every
single thing that you're uncomfortable
with you're gonna be uncomfortable for
your whole goddamn life get used to it
uh puberty is awkward you get into your
20s you get into your 30s your 40s your
50s you have a whole different set of
problems you're always gonna have a
problem always get used to it and get
tough not go to the doctor take medicine
for everything stop your natural
physical development put a puberty
Blocker we don't even know what these
things are really going to do in the
long run what's gonna happen in 20 30
years that we find this subset of people
that took puberty blockers I mean
they've grown extra [ __ ] heads out of
their neck like what's gonna happen we
don't know this is disgraceful I
couldn't tell you this isn't it you have
a daughter do not buy her anything
American Girl I don't care what she
thinks she wants she doesn't know she's
a kid parents are in charge you spend
your own money your nieces your nephews
your other kids and if they have this
[ __ ] throw it out and make a show of it
I was I was a parent of six girls I
bought a lot of dolls from American Girl
okay I'm the customer I don't want my
children to be exposed to this stuff if
they have images like this this is a
discussion between the parent hopefully
if they have a parent so fascinating how
she's transgender and she still
recognizes that you shouldn't shove that
[ __ ] down their throats because it's
just so bad for their health you know
it's so wild to me too is that I feel
like when you're little that's like
Prime Time Matrix programming because
that's when your brain's the biggest
sponge and you can Implement all the
fundamental subconscious ideas you want
in the kids when they're that young like
a kid can learn a language in in months
when they're little yeah that's correct
that's Madness like as an adult nobody
can do that unless you're like a chess
Grand Master genius so if you are a
puppet master genius you can say you're
gonna say why are we waiting until
they're adults to program them let's get
it in let's get it in while they're four
yeah let's start now somebody close to
them
um but not like in this book the last
couple of pages are references where
they can go to get puberty blockers and
they're encouraged to say well if you're
having image problems may she be on
puberty blockers for a few years until
you can figure yourself out this is
wrong leave our children alone let our
parents raise our children it you got to
read that book fascinating book and
we've got it here I tried to I tried to
order it what's up with that listen I
tried to order it on Amazon today it
wasn't coming until mid-January the
whole country is buying this thing up
that's why I listened to the audio clip
because I I couldn't even find they
don't have a printed ebook like a pdf
version why that's so crazy why why are
they all like token images too like
they're all I mean I guess I don't know
if there's like anything wrong with that
but it's just like something I noticed
it's like a little black girl with a
hearing aid it's like I don't know it's
it's to the point where like but it's
like it's like a normal girl is now
marginalized like isn't that funny like
you wanted someone to into Mart you know
making sure marginalized people are
represented that you're marginalizing
the the mass the masses like include
everybody you want to be inclusive
include everybody I get it I get it I
get that I think as if I was a little
girl and I had you know a hearing aid
and you feel like out of place all the
time I think it would be cool to see you
know more of it in pop culture i I think
that's not I I I'm not saying it's a bad
thing I literally just like it's just an
observation but it's everybody and our
thing and and you know American Girl uh
you're an American Girl household as
well and
um it's done a great job of being more
inclusive it has dolls of all shapes and
sizes disabilities backgrounds
backgrounds I think a company like
backgrounds what does that even mean
s made this controversial move I mean I
would assume that you know somebody at
some level of management in the company
executive level management this thing
knew that there would be reaction to
this don't be mean
maybe they wanted the publicity
everybody's all over the networks are
talking about this right now 68 dollar
drum set I think it's the wrong message
there's no way and so many of the images
in this book are like cartoon characters
um and it's like it's got to be fun I I
don't
uh it just bothers me as a parent of six
girls uh that this information is out
there
young girls I mean every every week you
have a different child they go through
so many things when they're going
through you know 12 13 14 puberty body
changes all that sort of stuff uh
they're going through so many things
that what they need is a parent that's
understanding uh the parent that helps
them get through it because you know
what next month you're going to have a
holy different bunch of issues with
these girls I know I raised all of them
and
um leave that up to the parents there's
so much information today honestly can I
say something about the parents here's
the thing is parents everybody's working
two jobs you know or at least they're
you know it let's say in a nor in a
traditional house I don't want to say
normal because there is no normal
anymore but any house the parent or
parents mostly are working full-time the
kids are going to activities everybody's
too freaking busy to do anything so when
a parent if a parent has a a girl who's
feeling bad about herself and she's like
my fat and I'm sad you know what and she
sees this book in the store she's gonna
look at it and go oh smart Girl's Guide
to good body image she'd be like you
know let me take that and I'll get it
for her and stick it in or stocking and
she'll stick it in the stocking never
having read it and that's because you
know what I I bought you tons of books I
didn't read them all before I gave them
to you which every Diary of a Wimpy Kid
book there ever was what if there was
some [ __ ] in there you know I was lucky
that we didn't have to worry about that
as parents we didn't have to worry about
whether there was secret Matrix messages
and books it was just a silly kids book
and that was fun but now they do have to
worry about it but if a parent's not
aware they're giving their little girl
this book thinking that they're doing
something good and you know she loves
American Girl maybe this will help him
feel better about herself and meanwhile
the kids there look getting it getting
introduced to oh I should be looking for
websites that will help me to become a
boy because being a girl is
uncomfortable you know so it's really
screwed up and it's really dangerous so
you can say oh it's parents
responsibility yeah but a parent can
only have so many responsibilities when
inflation's at groceries around [ __ ]
40 percent and they have to get a second
job now they get to read an entire book
before they buy give it to their kid too
because companies like this are trying
to brainwash children it's enough enough
I want to go backwards in time enough
going forward stop I'm mad I'm very mad
today I'm gonna go back I'm gonna go
back to when a kid had a hard time you
didn't sit and worry about their
feelings and freak out completely about
oh my God Sonny's sad today you know
what Sunny sad today that's life that
sucks they'll give him a hug and a
[ __ ] ice cream and carry on with my
day he'll be all right go backwards to
when we had to learn how to be tough you
told your kids suck it up life's a [ __ ]
I'm gonna stick with you through it
because life's hard but it's tough deal
with it let's go back because this ain't
working difficult
for young girls young boys or anyone to
grow up in that Society because they're
exposed so much material through the
internet I mean these people are on
their phones all day so many things that
they're exposed to at a very young age I
mean I grew up a long time ago I was
exposed to nothing I was just a little
kid out playing you know doing my thing
like sports and all of that stuff kids
today are being transgender isn't a
medical transition it's a process of
learning to love yourself for who you
are right so that's saying that that's
who you if you're transgender or
non-binary loving your body might feel
different than if like why is that it
does for a cisgender person why do
little kids need to be thinking about
this I don't know that's Haram
exposed to so much stuff do you think
that's evil immature mind is not quite
ready the left I don't even want to get
into this the left is is genuinely evil
in my opinion like I I see it as a
legitimately evil force like if you look
at all the horrible things that are
against isn't that wild it's not so
funny but like they created birth
control we're like I'm not gonna say who
did they create in birth control they're
the ones pushing abortion they're the
ones pushing taking away your rights
like all of that stuff it's the same
group of people pushing for it with the
same agenda oh the fact that they can be
talk they can be advocating for
censorship and calling the right
fascists that they can be advocating for
gun control and calling the right
fascists is is the stupidest thing in
the world because censorship and and
taking away guns that's what fascists
and Nazis do like so it's like the logic
doesn't doesn't add up but what what
what's just as a side note you you hit a
button what's the matter with birth
control and I know that and I know that
you know yeah get married in the Bible
all procreate blah blah blah but in the
room in the real world that we live in
birth control you know so look at I
don't know all this and it prevents
abortions what do you think I want to
know your thoughts on this okay I think
that realistically as a woman sex should
be more of a sacred thing so you
shouldn't need to be on birth control
you shouldn't go around sleeping with
everyone is that like that it starts
there I know this just this just sounds
as a woman but if a man can I know he
was who's he sleeping with if all the
women are so supposed to be so modest
that's the thing if the women became you
know less promiscuous than the dudes
would have to establish themselves more
because it's harder to get girls and
then it's just like the whole value of
men just raises by a whole if women stop
just sleeping around so much and then
also I think it's horrible for women's
mental health because like the way your
body revolves monthly is based around
the fact that you give birth you go
crazy for a week when you when you have
your period because you didn't have a
baby you know what I mean it's because
like you're you're killing or I think
like I don't know the exact science but
like the egg didn't get you know
fertilized or whatever and it's like
[ __ ] so then you get like you like you
know that your mental health gets all
whacked out so then no no you're not I'm
trying to explain this in the right way
but then it's like you're giving
yourselves chemicals to diminish like
the greatest gift that you have which is
giving life when I took like right yeah
and no I didn't but what I couldn't stop
thinking about was like when you give
birth you're not giving birth to just
like a baby or just like flesh it's like
a conscious being and like there's
nothing else that can create that than a
woman you know what I mean like that is
wild like I don't what even am I because
like as a woman you're creating that and
so then giving yourself birth control
and all this medicine is diminishing
that and then no wonder you get like you
get like depressed and [ __ ] you know
what I mean and it messes with you
because you're you're fighting nature
exactly you're fighting nature because
as a woman you're not meant to like
conquer and do all that [ __ ] that's what
you do as a guy but they don't talk
about gender roles and stuff you know
what I mean does that make sense or did
I sound crazy you don't sound that crazy
I feel like it's pretty logical it is
pretty logical and pretty right down and
pretty it pretty much simplifies
everything but even with sex and stuff
with birth control you can like time it
out on the monthly calendar of when you
can do it and you won't get pregnant why
does nobody know that how is that just
not it never talked about that yeah it's
like get on medicine like that's stuff
that's not talked about until you are
trying to get pregnant and then like
you're on a night before like before the
early stages of inverter in vitro IVF or
fertility treatments they have you
following your calendar so that when
you're most likely to get pregnant is is
when you should be you know playing
around but you're right that could be
used in pregnancy prevention also but
that is also a form of birth control
then so I I don't have a problem with
birth control because I you know if you
think about the the name of Planned
Parenthood and and if you took that and
you put that to married couple young
married couples who said they were going
to plan their family and then it sounds
kind of nice like we just want to make
sure that we do this right and you know
we're going to plan our kids because we
would love to have them I you know two
years apart a piece and we want to have
four of them and we want to do it once
we have a house and all that fine but so
it has like a nice it uses the word
Parenthood so it has like a nice
connotation to it well it's all the
irony of even using the term Parenthood
when you know know your your biggest
advocacy is is to not be a parent is is
a whole other they're all branding
Geniuses the left is some of like the
best branding experts ever and that's
what I find it so fascinating because
I'll look at something like the American
Girl dolls and I'll be like I find that
crazy that they've convinced people to
buy a 60 drum set that is [ __ ]
Madness to me like your branding and the
way you word you know you word
advertisements and do everything is all
to convince people to buy this 60 drum
set that costs you 12 cents to make that
is insane when you think about the toys
that you had but then a little that you
would before you got into electronics
and how absolutely happy you were you
know it to play little kids give a baby
like a year old give them a wooden spoon
and a pot and he'll sit there and bang
on it and be thrilled yeah just as happy
as just as happy as a yeah and 100
[ __ ] doll size drum set I find it
just as fascinating how they they've
managed to to work all those you know
those companies like Planned Parenthood
and getting aboard portions to where
it's like a good thing you know what I
mean like it doesn't even feel like
abortion like we've already said this
yeah whatever but I can say it's
as a parent it's it's a funny line to
walk though because you I can see all
the marketing stuff I can see how it's
[ __ ] I can see how it's so expensive
and it's all just part of the Matrix and
it's a trick but like at the same time
you don't want to be such a stick in the
mud about it that your kid doesn't never
get anything it doesn't have fun so you
have to you have to figure that out
things like this what makes the kids
questioning their own identity yeah and
uh honestly I don't think that's good
and you think about the age that they
put on a lot of their products is is for
girls around eight years old and many
times they're much younger than that
they do have a following above that as
well but I think of single digit numbers
and I mean there's an entire chapter in
here uh to body dysmorphia and I I can
imagine that there's many girls who you
know they're reading a lot of books at
that age and they open they're they're
going to read about this for the first
time uh and it wouldn't be coming from a
parent would be coming from a book that
in some cases says if you can't talk to
your parent around it go around them and
go to these resources to your point
Caitlyn um thank you very much for
joining us on this as you mentioned
everybody's talking about it what the
hell removing here is a very personal
choice and you should only do it if it
feels right for your body and after
talking to a parent why are you even
getting into this your [ __ ] dog
company you're supposed to be like what
remember Canada Ruby and they talk to
each other you play make-believe and
you're putting into you're getting into
armpit hair and shaving your legs what
is these people's doing puberty hair
start showing up in places you might not
have noticed before this hair can make
you feel self-conscious but there's
nothing dirty or wrong about it that's
just not true like shaving your armpits
is legit more sanitary so you're not
even telling the truth like I true in my
armpit hair because I don't want a
[ __ ] jungle it actually armpit hair
it breeds bacteria and so that's why you
you know yeah you should trim it because
it you're you can you'll stay less
stinky assuming you know of course you
shower every day but here's the thing
this here's a perfect example of what I
was talking about earlier this hair can
make you feel self-conscious but there's
nothing dirty or wrong about it I can
tell you as a [ __ ] fact never
occurred to me as a as a seven-year-old
girl who's their Market that the hair on
my legs was something to think about
never forget never and I had big sisters
who all shaved their legs and were all
you know hair makeup dresses kind of
girls now you're putting this in a kid's
head there's nothing dirty or wrong
about it what do you mean there's
nothing dirty wrong about it is there
something dirty or wrong about it now
I'm questioning putting questions this
kid should be worried about doing her
homework playing writing a little story
in her head right in her [ __ ] list to
Santa Claus and you got her worried
about her gender her armpit hair whether
or not and then now she's worried that
she doesn't have armpit hair do you have
armpit hair yet you do I don't have any
yet is there something wrong with me now
like shut up American Girl how dare they
plant this stuff in little girls heads
what a disgrace a ROM
everybody is yeah and I I just want to
get a lot of encouragement the young
girls out there it's going to be okay
you're going to do you think Caitlyn
Jenner has a death or what it is it's a
great they're not watching Caitlyn
they're not little girls they're not
watching Fox News but it was a good
reason
I don't give a [ __ ] wow that's something
for real I'll definitely be taking my
kid to American Girl doll seems Seems
like a good way to raise them well if
you have a daughter I'm not buying her
any American Girl dolls unless they get
their [ __ ] together there's these
Disney's getting their [ __ ] together and
Bob Iger is back imagine if we just
listened to the Liberals where we would
go like if we just followed all the [ __ ]
they're saying what like where we would
go well we're seeing where we are we're
in a Land of racial division children
being confused and pushed into into
hormone therapy and bodily mutilation
which is not which is actually either
keeping their suicide rate or increasing
their suicide rates uh and increasing
their anxiety and depression so yeah
we're seeing where it's going we're also
going into uh extreme inflation and
poverty around the nation because
because of their economic policies so
we're watching it meta is down over 70
percent good [ __ ] them all right guys
thank you so much for watching if you're
interested in learning my social media
tips and how to make money online join
my Academy it's the month of December
I'm running a holiday sale so whatever
day of the month it is holiday Christmas
whatever day of the month it is that's
all you pay for your first month so if
you're watching this on the 10th of
December you only pay ten dollars to get
in and it's typically a hundred dollar
program so so hurry up not bad stuff
hurry up before the 31st yeah the Link's
in the description and then you use the
code PhD and then whatever day of the
month it is so if it's the 12th you use
PhD 12 and you buy for twelve dollars
pretty cool stuff and yeah be sure to
follow my Instagram and then I'll see
you later
gone
[Music]
[Music]